My mother raised us on real food and she
was a fan of Adele Davis who was the
pioneering slightly out of the
mainstream nutritionist,
but a lay woman,
right.
And so then,
then a lot of people attacked her for
not knowing enough,
uh,
who came out of California,
um,
in the sixties and seventies.
She had a pretty big following and Adele
Davis had very simple principles,
all of which have been pretty much born
out by the,
by the subsequent science,
wholefood b vitamins,
real meat,
real milk,
um,
traditional fats.
She has a few clunkers that don't
survive the test of time,
which you come across in her books.
But on the whole,
everything,
everything she said prove to be true.
And so my mother raised us on whole
wheat bread and,
uh,
the proverbial black strap,
molasses.
We made granola once a week.
The children had,
uh,
an assignment to make granola.
Um,
we also ate all the meats.
It was not a Vegan hit becoming our
little farm.
Um,
so we had very traditional simple
American meals,
like fried chicken,
meatloaf.
Um,
I remember,
uh,
food I regard as one of our super frugal
meals was macaroni with tuna and cream
sauce,
which I loved.
Um,
my mother used to dip her toast in the
bacon fat and nothing was off limits,
um,
except white sugar and white flour.
Those would have been my mother's
standards.
And she used to say,
no matter how little money we have will
always have real maple syrup,
real olive oil and real butter.
We also had a cow and chickens.
And in addition to the vegetables,
we were growing our vegetable farm.
So we drank raw milk.
We didn't make any cheese or dairy
products.
Um,
that would have been more homesteady
than we were.
And we were really busy as commercial
vegetable farmers,
but we did have fresh eggs and fresh
milk.
And then what we couldn't raise
ourselves,
we bought or bartered for the farmer's
markets.
And in the dead of winter,
we shopped at the supermarkets.
My concept of real food was grounded in
my mother's lessons for us.
Um,
uh,
which were that it should be whole,
it should be traditional.
It should be simple,
shouldn't be processed,
a small number of ingredients.
Um,
and then I sort of went off track and,
uh,
in my teens and 20s,
became a Vegan and a vegetarian and
tried to low fat diets and low saturated
fat diets and low cholesterol diets.
And,
um,
the,
and,
and the reason I did that is it was not
so much their thumb in the face of my
mother,
although perhaps we're,
we're all acting against our parents in
some ways.
Um,
but more because it was,
um,
the conventional wisdom of the time in
the late eighties and the early 1990s
that less fat was good,
less saturated fat,
good less animal fat,
less cholesterol,
more plant foods.
So I assumed that if all those things
were true,
that,
um,
a nonfat Vegan diet was probably the
best of all.
Um,
and,
and that's what I tried and,
uh,
things went,
went along fine.
No one would have called me sick.
Um,
but on Vegan and low fat diets,
in fact,
my health suffered and I was 25 pounds
heavier than I am now.
And I had a host of minor minor
complaints,
um,
and,
and no one really would have ever called
me ill or,
or certainly they wouldn't have
suspected my perfect diet because I was
not a junk food vegan or vegetarian.
I had brown rice and beans.
I,
olive oil,
light fruits and vegetables.
Um,
I just didn't eat,
um,
many traditional foods.
How,
how I now understand it.
So what brought me back to real food,
um,
was,
was a wonderful serendipity.
I was living in London and I had started
the first American style farmer's
markets in London in 1999 and when I
grew up in the,
in the Washington dc area,
at the farmer's markets,
there were the vegetable people like us
and the fruit guys.
And then there was the plant lady and
the honey man and the baker at farmers
markets.
When I started my first little farmer's
market in London,
I had farmers even at my first little
market with only 16 producers selling
grass fed and pastured beef and lamb and
pork and chicken.
They were selling raw milk cheeses and
cream and um,
and sausages and meat pies.
And fish and all sorts of wonderful
things.
So then I got a book contract and that
was to write the farmers' market
cookbook.
And I had just been dabbling around with
eggs and with fish.
And I was no longer Vegan and no longer
a vegetarian,
but I wasn't eating.
I was not yet a carnivore or an omnivore
even.
And so I didn't want to write a
vegetarian or even a fish and eggs
farmers' market cookbook.
I felt I had to honor all the food
producers at the markets.
And we'll the eaters as well.
So I,
I looked around and I saw that the,
the farmers have these wonderful
traditional foods,
the meat,
eggs,
dairy,
the fats,
um,
we're healthy and happy people and seem
to enjoy their food.
And,
and the eaters were healthy and happy
people and to certainly enjoyed all
those foods.
And I began to wonder whether I
shouldn't try these foods.
So for my cookbook,
I tried every food at our markets and
wrote recipes and ate all the recipes.
And it was along the way that I slowly
became a,
an omnivore again.
Um,
and with each food I ate with each fat,
with each rich thing,
with each red meat,
with each forbidden and taboo thing.
Would g w with each item that the
cardiologists were banning,
um,
in the u s and in Britain as well,
my health improved quite dramatically.
I lost 25 pounds.
I didn't have to exercise as much.
I used to run six miles,
six,
six times a week.
I'd colds and flu and flu season.
My nails and hair and skin were dry.
My digestion was terrible.
All of those problems melted away.
When,
when I became an element of Oregon.